hätte mich gefreut wenn das Gesetz jetzt
wo wir uns geeinigt haben wo es
aufgesetzt ist wo alle Fraktionen
regierungstragenden Fraktion ist
beschlossen haben dann auch formal
abgeschlossen wird dass wir natürlich
auch gut gewesen nach den vielen Wochen
und Monaten der Debatte aber es ist eben
auch formal geeinigt es ist inhaltlich
beschlossen es gibt ja auch heute gar
keine Debatte mehr über die Inhalte des
Gesetzes sondern nur noch über diese
Form dann hat das Gericht halt so
entschieden dass die
Opposition mehr Zeit haben soll sich mit
dem Gesetz zu beschäftigen das ist okay
das ist ich habe da wohnen Respekt vor
den Urteilen aus Karlsruhe so und jetzt
machen wir das eben dann im September
nach den Sommer